welcome back to CBS mornings we are
excited to welcome our next guest actor
Beth Bears she starred as former Rich
Girl Caroline Channing on the series Two
Broke Girls and now she plays Gemma
Johnson in the CBS hit comedy the
neighborhood it is about a white family
from the Midwest who moved to a mainly
black neighborhood in Los Angeles now in
season five this clip from tonight's new
episode shows Gemma asking husband Dave
to be on his best behavior at an
upcoming bachelor party watch
I'm just saying you don't have a great
history at Bachelor parties
I don't know what you're talking about
a party in Cancun
Matthews in New Orleans Gary's bachelor
party that started in Las Vegas and
ended in jail
it was a detention cell at the Bellagio
[Laughter]
Beth Bears joins us live in studio good
morning good morning so it's a comedy
but you guys tackle everything from
gentrification pregnancy loss addiction
I mean these are some tough topics in a
comedy show you know it's interesting
because on a multicam comedy in
particular you don't normally get to
dive into those kinds of deeper issues
because it's supposed to be all about
the laugh or the joke and it's supposed
to make you feel good but I think the
best kind of Comedy has a dramatic
tension and then a release and I think
from day one our show and our writers
and Cedric everyone behind it really
wanted this to say something and also
bring people together and what better
way to bring people together than to
laugh yes and always at the end of the
day it's about love it's about community
and we laugh
and I think that that's I'm super proud
to be on a show that says something and
also brings you Joy you know the world's
hard enough definitely brings us joy
talk to us about motherhood you gave
birth a year ago I have my baby Emma we
can call you Emma's Mom you can call me
Emma George's mom yes eight months now
she's eight months I was just telling
you it's the best thing of my life my my
mom who's a grandma for the first time
it's the best thing about her what's her
grandma's name Grandma so her name's
Maureen but it's Grandma Momo we call
her Momo I like that yep that's what
we're trying to you know and pop pop
that's what we're trying to get my dad
to be but you said being a mom being
Emma mom I know even in this
conversation you said something about my
daughter my daughter when you first have
a baby you want to say my daughter my
daughter my daughter I so get that but
you said she has taught you about mother
that being Emma's mom has taught you
about motherhood on this show what do
you mean so playing Gemma in the
neighborhood after Two Broke Girls it
was my first time playing a mom and
Tashina Arnold they'll never forget and
met me and she was like once you go mom
you never go go back like on the
neighborhood because like I had never
played them on before and she's like now
you're in it but I feel like playing
Gemma for five years before having Emma
and playing out some parenting uh you
know dilemmas on the neighborhood and
even the journey with pregnancy my
character experienced a miscarriage and
it was a really emotional episode for
all involved but I had a really just
beautiful time being able to play that
out and learn from it and then now being
a mom I feel like I've learned a lot
from Hank who plays my son on the show
we've had to have difficult
conversations as mother and son so I
feel like I'm fully prepared for Emma
yeah I feel like I got you yeah I got
this you mentioned Cedric and Tashina
Arnold and they are two of the most
versatile talents in the business and
they've been doing it a long time
you learned on camera maybe even off
camera working with them to Sheena and
her sisters
have sort of become speaking of
motherhood
they've been my go-to about everything
because Zanae has a young son and and I
feel like to Sheena
first of all she's just she jumps off
the comedy Cliff with me I've never had
a chemistry with someone where I could
just jump off and I know we don't care
about how we look we don't care about
how gross or goofy it is and I feel like
that in life we have conversations she
said I can ask her any question at any
time and I never have to worry and I
feel the same way and just with
motherhood she's been amazing and Cedric
was on Two Brothers jumping off the
comedy Cliff yeah I like that yeah yeah
in real life you rescue horses
yes I sound like a professional horse
race yeah you have two what does that do
for you why do you do everything
especially my mental health you know
I've suffered from anxiety for years and
I feel like horses they're prey animals
so they're constantly in their bodies
because they have to be because of
danger and by being around them you're
forced to be in the present moment it's
like easier than meditating and closing
your eyes they just force you to be
present so spending time with them is
truly like the best meditation I've ever
had my road rage got better really after
being around horses I would have never
picked you as a road rager you wouldn't
Gail so let me tell you
those are the ones that surprised you
yeah yeah
they don't want to have road rage one
time you guys I might have beeped at
someone because they weren't pulling out
and two seconds later I realized it was
Jennifer Coolidge my co-star
and she was like bet and we were
cracking up and I was like oh my gosh
but now I don't beat them
if I saw you in road rage I would look
at you and just think oh that lady's
having a bed or they'd be like that's a
crazy lady from the neighborhood like
she's an actress we should say
congratulations you got picked up for a
sixth season you gave your 100th episode
Bravo Bravo and big milestone Beth we've
told the network all of us that we'll do
this for 100 years like we're all so
happy we love each other the set is so
fun we have talent shows that's cornhole
competitions like we're it's concedric
play cornhole I've done I don't know
many black people
[Laughter]
I know I know right he can play I got
that one shot hole in one on only one
take but he got it in every other take
so Cedric yeah
you made this fun thank you I love you
you can watch tonight's new episode of
the neighborhood at 8 7 Central it's
called cornhole CBS of course you can
stream it on Paramount Plus